WE WILL TELL THAT YOU IN A
MINUTE.
BUT, FIRST, JUST BEFORE DAWN
THIS MORNING THE FBI RAIDED
THE FLORIDA HOME OF LONG
TIME TRUMP ADVISOR ROGER
STONE WHO WILL BE JOINING
NEWS A MINUTE.
THE CNN PRODUCER STOOD
ACROSS THE STREET RECORDING
IT ALL WITH A CAMERA AS
DOZENS OF HEAVILY ARMED
AGENTS PILED OF VEHICLES AND
STORMED STONE'S HOUSE SOME
CARRIED RIFLES WITH EXTRA
MAGAZINES HEAVY MILITARY
GEAR.
TACTICAL GLOVES, ONE AGENT
CARRIED TWO SEPARATE RIFLES
IN ADDITION TO HIS SIDE ARM.
THE MAN IN FRONT OF HIM
APPEARED TO HAVE A FLASH
BANG GRENADE ON BELT.
THE WHOLE TEAM SCRAMMED BLED
OVER STONE'S LAWN AND
POUNDED ON DOOR.
STONE APPEARED HE WAS
BAREFOOT AND WEARING A
T-SHIRT.
THE AGENTS SLAPPED HIM IN
HANDCUFFS.
STONE TOLD THE AGENTS WIFE
WAS UPSTAIRS WITH THEIR
DOGS.
STONE'S WIFE IS DEAF AND
DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
HAPPENING.
STONE WAS WORRIED THAT ONE
IN THE MEN IN TACTICAL GEAR
MIGHT SHOOT HER BY ACCIDENT.
TRAGEDIES LIKE THAT
REGULARLY OCCUR DURING LAW
ENFORCEMENT RAIDS AND THAT'S
WHY FEDERAL AGENTS DON'T
RAID THE HOMES OF PEOPLE
LIKE ROGER STONE.
THERE IS NO NEED.
TO SAY STONE HAS NO HISTORY
OF VIOLENCE.
HE DOESN'T RUN INTERNATIONAL
DRUG CARTEL.
HE HASN'T BEEN CHARGED WITH
MURDER OR EVEN WITH SPYING
FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN.
ROGER STONE IS ACCUSED OF
LYING DURING THE COURSE OF
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES,
DURING NORMAL TIMES,
PROSECUTORS WOULD JUST CALL
HIS LAWYER AND ARRANGE A
SURRENDER.
STONE IS 66 YEARS OLD.
HE IS SO BROKE FROM
MUELLER-RELATED LEGAL
EXPENSES THAT HE CAN'T
AFFORD HEALTH INSURANCE.
HE IS HARDLY A FLIGHT RISK.
BUT, NO.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY DID.
INSTEAD THE FEDS WENT WITH
AUTOMATIC WEAPONS AND A
CAMERAMAN FROM CNN.
YOU DON'T NEED TO BE A ROGER
STONE PARTISAN, A FAN TO SEE
THAT THERE IS SOMETHING
WRONG WITH WHAT HAPPENED
THIS MORNING.
THE MOST POWERFUL PERSON IN
AMERICA IS NOW AN UNELECTED
PROSECUTOR WITH NO
FUNCTIONAL OVERSIGHT OVER
WHAT HE DOES.
ROBERT MUELLER COMMANDS IN
EFFECT HIS OWN DOMESTIC
ARMY.
YOU JUST SAW THEM.
CAN HE USE IT HOWEVER HE
LIKES AND HE DOES.
MUELLER CRUSHES PEOPLE WHEN
IT'S NOT EVEN NECESSARY TO
DO IT.
WEAK PEOPLE MOSTLY.
AND HE DOES IT IN WAYS THAT
ARE CLEARLY DESIGNED TO SEND
A POLITICAL MESSAGE.
THAT IS NOT HOW DEMOCRACIES
ARE SUPPOSED TO WORK.
AND YOU WOULD THINK OUR
MEDIA WOULD BE BOTHERED BY
THIS.
REPORTERS ARE NOT SUPPOSED
TO SIDE WITH PROSECUTORS WHO
ABUSE THEIR POWER OR ANYONE
ELSE WHO ABUSES POWER.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO HOLD
THE POWERFUL TO ACCOUNT.
THAT'S WHY THEY EXIST.
BUT NOT ANYMORE.
NOW THEY ARE ALL IN THE SAME
TEAM.
ROBERT MUELLER IS A HERO TO
OUR PRESS CORPS.
WHEN HIS AGENTS RAID THE
HOME OF AN ELDERLY MAN
CHARGED WITH PIDDLY CRIMES
THEY AIR THE TAPE AND THEY
CELEBRATE.
>> ROGER STONE, LIKE DONALD
TRUMP IS, A POLITICAL CONMAN
WHO HE IS' SHOMAN SCHTICK
HAS FINALLY CAUGHT ONE HIM.
>> IF YOU LOOK UP THE WORD
SCUM BAG IN THE DICTIONARY
YOU ARE GOING TO SEE ROGER
STONE'S PICTURE.
>> THERE I'M JUST SO DAMN
HAPPY THIS GUY IS INDICTED
AND ARRESTED.
IS HE A HORRIBLE HUMAN
BEING.
HE IS A THUG.
HE IS A BULLY.
BYE-BYE, BABY.
KARMA IS A BITCH.
>> HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
HAVE HER IN CHARGE OF YOUR
LIFE.
SO DAMN HAPPY.
SO BAREFOOT ROGER STONE IS
TAKEN TO JAIL.
IF THAT THRILLS YOU, IT MAY
BE TIME TO TAKE A BREAK,
PAUSE, AND REASSESS WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO YOUR SOUL.
BUT NO ONE REASSESSED TODAY.
THEY REJOICED.
ONE FAME MIA MUST NEOCON
SUMMED IT UP THIS WAY GIVEN
POLICE PROCLIVITIES MAYBE
ROGER STONE WOULD ENJOY
PRISON.
GET IT?
STONE MAY GET RAPED BEHIND
BARS.
HOW AWESOME IS THAT?
SO HOW SHOULD THE REST OF US
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T SPENDING
OUR LIVES ON TWITTER FEEL
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED THIS
MORNING?
IS AMERICA SAFER?
NOT IF YOU BELIEVED IN THE
RUSSIA COLLUSION STORY WE
STILL HAVEN'T CAUGHT THOSE
VALE ALANS TWO YEARS IN
STILL NO EVIDENCE AT ALL
THAT ANY AMERICAN COMMITTED
AN ACTUAL CRIME DURING THE
2016 ELECTION.
ROGER STONE, FOR EXAMPLE,
STANDS ACCUSED OF MISS DEEDS
COMMITTED LONG AFTER THE
VOTES WERE COUNTED.
HIS ALLEGE CRIMES AROSE WHEN
INVESTIGATION INTO OTHER
CRIMES WE HAVE NOT YET
FOUND.
THE CHARGES AGAINST STONE
INCLUDE OBSTRUCTION OF
PROCEEDINGS, WITNESS
TAMPERING, FIVE COUNTS OF
LYING TO CONGRESS.
THE CORE OF IT, OF THE
CHARGES, IS THAT STONE
MISCHARACTERIZED HIS
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE LEFT
WING TALK RADIO HOST CALLED
RANDY CRECKO.
HE SERVED AS INTERMEDIARY
WITH JULIAN ASSANGE WHO RUNS
WIKILEAKS.
NOW, NONE OF WHAT STONE OR
CREDICO DID WITH ASSANGE IS
ILLEGAL.
JOURNALISTS DID THAT KIND OF
THING ALL THE TIME.
IF THE LYING WE ARE TOLD
MUST BE PUNISHED WITH YOU
JAIL TIME.
OKAY.
BUT, AGAIN, WE HAVE NOTED
THIS BEFORE.
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT HERE
IS A BRAND NEW STANDARD OF
CONDUCT, ONE THAT NOBODY HAS
BEEN PAYING CLOSE ATTENTION
TO THIS COUNTRY FOR THE LAST
20 YEARS WOULD EVEN
RECOGNIZE THERE SAN AWFUL
LOT OF LYING OUT THERE.
AN AWFUL LOT.
A LOT OF NOT ACKNOWLEDGED AS
LYING.
EVERY TIME AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT LIES TO A FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION OFFICER THAT'S A
FELONY.
ANY TIME A POLITICIAN LIES
UNDER NOTE CONGRESS THAT'S A
POTENTIAL JAIL TERM.
BOTH OF THOSE HAPPEN A LOT
BUT NOBODY IS EVER CHARGED
FOR ANY OF IT.
NOW, THIS IS HARDLY A
DEFENSE OF LYING.
LYING IS BAD.
IT'S CORROSIVE AND ONE OF
THE MAIN PROBLEMS WITH OUR
POLITICAL SYSTEM, ACTUALLY.
EVERYBODY LIES ALL THE TIME.
BUT THERE IS, AT LEAST, ONE
THING THAT IS WORSE THAN
LYING.
EVEN LYING UNDER OATH.
AND IT'S THE SELECTIVE
APPLICATION OF FEDERAL LAW.
ONE STANDARD FOR THE
POWERFUL AND WELL-CONNECTED,
FORMER ATTORNEY GENERALS,
FOR EXAMPLE, ANOTHER
STANDARD FOR BAREFOOT
66-YEAR-OLD MEN WITH
UNFASHIONABLE POLITICAL
VIEWS.
SOME PEOPLE SKATE, OTHERS
ARE DESTROYED.
IT ALL DEPENDS ON WHO YOU